so a moment ago we talked about Civil
War some people might say that's crazy
fine if you think it's crazy by all
means you can think whatever you want I
must be crazy I don't care on major
networks will they talk about this
probably not some of them maybe we
recently saw MSNBC actually run a
segment said could we be facing a second
American Civil War now this is a
conversation that's been in mainstream
newspapers for years
but see on this show we're willing to
talk about this from Fox News arrest
fouchy Trends on Twitter as Doctor faces
criticism for controversial virus
research testing on dogs I think there's
only one cable TV show that would
actually get more serious than us and
you know who that is would you have a
guess one Cable cable team Brad gotfield
tastes pretty good but no that's kind of
a chuckle Carlson Tucker Carlson Tucker
Carlson goes a lot further than than I
would you know on a lot of these issues
so when we talk about fauci and and
people wanting to be arrested and stuff
oh we'll talk about these ideas we'll
talk about the potential conflict of
Civil War Tucker goes all in on all of
it so that's why I think obviously his
ratings are so high and then why is it
that all these other networks writing
from the garbage because it's fake and
everyone knows it's fake and they're not
talking about real things you go outside
there's no food on the shelves at your
store you're asking yourself what's
going on you turn on CNN nothing orange
man bed you're trying to MSNBC nothing
orange man bed you turn on Fox and
they're like inflation's bad at Biden's
fault or worse and you open up the
Washington Post and it's lower your
expectations right why would I expect
there to be pasta and frozen vegetables
in my local grocery store both of which
they've been like running low on forever
now yeah um yeah it's it's it's really
something but let's we'll let's talk
about this arrest fouchy thing because
I don't know if fauci should be arrested
over this there's a story going around
where it shows two dogs they're beagles
and their heads are secured in a box
full of infected sand flies and the dogs
had their vocal cords slit so they
couldn't bark or whimper as their faces
were devoured by ravenous insects
now a lot of people are saying you
should be arrested for it and I think
there's a couple things that they're
that are good here people are starting
to wake up to the kind of research being
done for their for their benefit for
their privileges a lot of This research
is unnecessary and insane and people are
asking like why would you do that we
know the Flies would Devour the face of
the dog and put it in agony
but I think a lot of people need to
realize
the benefits the wonderful technology
the medicines you have it's because we
experiment in animals sometimes dogs
yeah and actually specifically with sand
flies I don't know exactly what they
were researching with sand flies but
with sand flies they're major carriers
of parasitic diseases which are one of
the few things that we really have
terrible treatments for like this this
disease called leishmaniasis it's very
prominent in Central and South America
that does like horrible things to people
um like it literally like rots your face
from the inside out
um and because it primarily affects poor
people in these areas it's only
Government testing that there's really
an incentive to find any sort of cure
because the pharmaceutical companies
aren't in it because there's no you know
Financial incentive for it so yeah I
mean actually I don't know exactly what
they were doing with the sand flies but
I can see where doing you know research
on parasitic diseases for all the Havoc
at rigs you know testing on dogs might
be necessary a good friend of mine from
high school is a
um is a um
is a biology professor at UT Austin and
you know he talked all of that biology
what is he neurology professor and uh
you know he would tell me all the
stories he had to do the stories of all
the experiments he had to do in monkeys
and stuff I mean it's just absolutely
necessary for the advancement of
humanity
um if you care about that sort of thing
now as for lying to Congress that's
something that maybe we should talk
about right this reminds us about you
Andrew Cuomo how they went after him for
the girl with him diddling with the
girls as opposed to sending all those
old people into nursing homes and it's
like they evokes the emotional hashtag
trending thing where like what he really
should be busted for is lying to
Congress well if it's what you said it
was there at least should be a debate
but we shouldn't be giving him the
benefit of the doubt because he doesn't
deserve any of it because he's been
lying through his teeth about so many
things and at least we deserve answers
to really find out what was the true
cause and the true reason of these
studies I mean there's there's even
reports of fauci-funded experiments that
literally were used to destroy destroy
portions of monkey's brain that would
magnify Terror so they could scare the
crap out of them and study fear so
there's there's so many different why
they would do that yeah what are they
trying to learn about primate fear
exactly and again uh apes or or 97
identical to human DNA there's a lot of
weird stuff happening and there should
be a lot more transparency a lot more
accountability because we have to
understand there's some you know beauty
products that are tested and absolutely
cruel and inhumane waste torture animals
it's we can't even describe what happens
here the show would get taken down
immediately all for beauty products like
that there should be a line there should
be a discussion there should be more
information we don't have any of that we
have Dr fauci financing essentially the
torturing of puppies why he did it at
this point of view we don't know but I'm
willing to suspect something far more
Sinister something far more worse based
on his prior behavior for my own
personal perspective I think fauci had a
mustache he shaved it off since then but
back then then he was twirling it saying
we're gonna kill these dogs the fun I
could see it that was it that was the
only reason at this point maybe I think
just be honest let's be real like we
don't know that's not a fact we don't
have a Smoking Gun here but I'm not
willing to exclude that out of our
current reality with the way that he's
been treating Humanity but it is insane
that we you know we've got he's gotten
far more attention for the testing on
dogs than they lie in Congress about
funding research at the Wuhan facility
that likely caused the pants to the
point where Stephanopoulos and and he
was denying that he ever did it uh that
he ever said that they were doing that
they ever did gain a function and then
they were like let's play a clip from
Rand Paul where he comes at you and they
give this three or four second clip of
Rand Paul and then George Stephanopoulos
just lofting softballs over to him
saying and by the way our experts
confirmed you didn't do gain of a gain
of function right in fact she's like
yeah of course we didn't do gain of
function insane yeah insane data
function research would be the
manipulation of viruses to make them
more infectious to human type cells
correct that is correct and you didn't
do that no we only took cells and and
viruses and modified them so that there
would be more infectious to humans we
didn't do gain of function and look how
stupid Rand Paul is let's all let's all
focus on that well where'd they rewa
recently like rewriting the cdc's
website or whatever to redefine gain a
function or whatever I mean it's insane
and the thing is he didn't just lie
about this he got indignant yeah good
job and and and it's just
this is connected to this larger
narrative remember Facebook banned all
discussion of the lab leak because it
was quote unquote misinformation that
was all covering up this our culture has
a rot at the core and there are corrupt
people like fauci who let me just
explain to you the level of insanity we
are dealing with when Rand Paul holds up
the study that says chimeric virus
creation to increase infectivity on
humans definition of gain of function
fauci this this study says funded by the
NIH and fauci goes we did not fund it
it's like
literally holding the evidence and then
what do you get from The Establishment
and from the left and from Amazon BC
it's not true ignore it and that's the
insanity let's also mention here again
that Senator Rand Paul is a medical
doctor doctor Senator Rand Paul yes so
it's not like he doesn't have some clue
what he's talking about here when he
looks at a research paper he's an actual
trained medical doctor and then the left
goes he's an ophthalmologist who hasn't
practiced in years Dr fauci's an
infectious disease expert who hasn't
practiced in three decades Rand Paul
literally volunteers his time and goes
down to places like Haiti and gives free
surgeries to people who can't afford it
so he he's been practicing medicine on
and off yes but at the same time the
mainstream media vilified him attacked
him every step of the way because he
correctly now called out Dr fauci which
the NIH doctor fauci's own organization
that he was running called him out on
yes in the untrained media do such a
great job of presenting method
information to us too you know they're
certainly in the catbird seat when it
comes to criticizing Rand Paul yeah
everything causes cancer and everything
doesn't I love how the media does this
when I was little I see a story it was
like smelling coffee could prevent
cancer or 11. and it's just like it was
a slow news day they looked up a journal
they said here's a study that says one
thing the next day Smelling Coffee could
cause cancer news at 11. cholesterol was
Notorious they'd be like oh cholesterol
is great cholesterol is bad cholesterol
is actually very good for you watch out
for cholesterol I remember I remember
when the news of the NIH letter came out
and broke fauci was on the mainstream
media they didn't question him about
this right they were talking about how
great it is that kids were going to be
vaccinated uh from ages 5 to 11 and and
and up and and meanwhile you know there
needs to be a debate there was a Yale
epidemologist who was very important
with early coveted treatment who just
came out recently and said that he would
pull his child out of public school if
they have public vaccine mandate in that
particular School epidemiologists
epidemiologist yeah Yale epidemologist
Dr Henry Rish came out and uh he put out
a very important statement saying if it
comes to it I will homeschool my child
rather than put him in a public school
where he has to take a vaccine and he
was critically important for early
covid-19 treatment he was the authority
on it and and he deserves to be heard
his voice deserves to be elevated and I
wish there was a debate I wish there was
a conversation between him and Dr fauci
Who's telling people that it's going to
be great that all children are going to
be vaccinated Dr fauci Works in an
office with a picture of himself a giant
portrait of himself wow
that's that's great huh we got pictures
of Biden because we love Biden Lydia's
got a big old picture can you show the
people show the people oh it's you can't
really see it it's a little here let me
zoom out a little bit there's a picture
of Biden because we love and respect our
presidents right look at that beautiful
it's actually photos are just listening
it's a horror photo yeah his face is
like kind of drooping and melting off
he's kind of sinister look as he smells
Lydia I love it because he's a
disgusting creep yep man you see the uh
that that Cornholio pose man the
imaginary jet pack
do you know red STEEZ is on Twitter
Stephen Miller yeah other Stephen Miller
yeah the other one yeah he put up this
thing was like apparently like one of
the classic symptoms of like dementia
Alzheimer's is clenched fists like that
I've seen it yeah and I look I'm not
speculating whether or not Biden has
dementia per se but the point is is if
if this were Trump or any Republican or
anyone that the media didn't like If
This Were Bernie Sanders this would be
you know a week's worth of news Cycles
about whether or not that he has
dementia I feel that screaming the truth
at someone that doesn't want to hear it
is is fruitless it may have some impact
but it's such a diminishing return it's
like wind resistance terminal velocity
you can't you can't get past their brain
cloud so there's I'm trying to think of
other ways you got to make them figure
it out on their own like set them up to
figure it out walk into it and be like
hey I figured out that
Biden is losing his you know whatever
his mental capacity if that's what's
happening but to tell them that just
doesn't seem they don't seem that it
doesn't seem to yeah clinchtan's a
symptom of Alzheimer's yeah it is it is
but but to Ian's point I think that he's
on to something help me zoom in a little
bit more again well this could also
explain sorry just one one small uh
important tidbit here before I take it
off to Lydia this could explain why we
are on day 279 of the hundred days of
masking
sorry go ahead yeah yeah for sure well
what I was going to say was that to
Ian's point he was talking about how you
can't convince someone to change their
mind by giving them new information
because you're just contradicting them
this is something Scott Adams talks
about a lot and in general I would
recommend being incredibly compassionate
even when it's really hard because what
is that quote that people won't care
what you told them they'll only care how
you made them feel at the end of the day
yeah no I think this is true and this is
something that you know conservatives in
general really stink at yeah they need
to like approach the conversation like I
understand why you you know that you
feel this way I understand that maybe
you've had difficulties because of X Y
and Z but here you know here's why I'm
telling you that I disagree you know
there needs to be some sort of
acknowledgment on a human level also
rather than like you know I look I like
Ben Shapiro but like facts don't care
about your feelings doesn't get you very
far feelings don't care about your facts
sorry yes I feel what you feel is the
way to go understanding what they feel
that's kind of it's kind of too cold but
when you feel what they're feeling it
sucks because like they're feeling
terrified and like they're losing their
mind but if you allow yourself to feel
it for a minute while you're talking to
them then this is to believe you it's
sales and uh manipulation 101. is the
first thing you have to do in order to
change anyone's opinion is have a
rapport and so that's why a very common
sales tactic would be like hey you know
nice to meet you man uh where are you
from Mark
Bend Oregon Bend Oregon no no seriously
my brother lives up there yeah my
brother's amazing I wonder if you guys
ever bumped into each other that's so
cool I can't believe we have so much in
common well I live in Alexandria now but
I'm originally from Ben wow uh so
actually uh I do have a brother who
lives in Bend but so what you do is when
you're when when you're doing sales or
fundraising activism you start off just
with like hey nice to meet you where are
you from you know you find something and
then no matter what they say you say
something to compliment it and show that
you share a positive emotion and then
you're opening the door another thing we
talked about is something called the yes
train get someone to say yes seven times
they're more likely to acquiesce to
whatever your demand is so like if you
want to sell them with pizza you'll be
like hey look you you know you're
probably it's lunch time right right
you're looking for food I'd imagine at
some point right and then eventually
okay great I got a pizza right here here
you go you want it right right the last
three times I've been in a car
dealership that I've always been
complimented on my shirt huh
I think I was talking about I don't
think my shirt was particularly great I
was talking about my dad and he was like
can you can you believe it they're
they're trying to stop people from being
able to take the vaccine if they want in
these certain places and I was like
that's crazy man if if it was a
dangerous disease then I could
understand like it was like I I just
felt and got what he was saying even
though it wasn't what I agreed with and
and then it's immediately started
telling him what I thought that's the
way to get through to people I I was a
little vague about what transpired just
now on purpose the end the end the
unfortunate reality for me was when I
was working at these non-profits is that
there's a very easy formulaic way to get
people to change their opinions it works
every time and if you're willing to do
that you'll win and if you're not
willing to do that then you're in
trouble so being blunt with people I
feel like is the right thing to do but
the right thing isn't always the
effective thing and so like you
mentioned it's actually One Step Beyond
that
uh it's it's it's actively lying to
manipulate that gets you the most
successful outcome and uh
man I I think these these these you know
charity organizations these non-profits
I used to do this stuff once I found out
that they were lying I quit I couldn't
do it I was like I thought I was being
honest I thought I was doing a good
thing and then once you realize they've
actually formulated these lies
specifically to make money off people
and trick them and what my friends
described it me and my friends to
describe it as selling hopes and dreams
to people or selling them nothing
like people would go out in the street
and sell hair products and packages they
have these guys that go around and
they'll be alike they'll walk up to
girls and be like oh your hair is
amazing like you should definitely check
out the salon and then give them the
coupon and then they get money when the
coupon is used and then we would always
laugh like we you know they'd see us we
would do we'd be fundraising and we'd be
like we don't sell anything we literally
just tell people to give us their money
and they do and they'd be like wow
people are animals we think a lot of
times that we're so smart I do for sure
but like like a dog if you treat it
right and you reward it when you want
want it to repeat itself I disagree I
had uh I I knew someone
I met someone at uh Columbia who said
that they used
um
pavlovian reinforcement to get their
roommate to do chores for them
by offering them candies that they
really liked whenever they would do
something
and then when they wanted the dishes
done they would plot the candies and
then be like oh would you mind doing the
dishes and they'd be like yeah and then
afterwards she'd hand them some candy
and they were just like they didn't
realize they had been manipulated thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time